for intense periods of our lives we
suffer the agony of unrequited love our
sorrow is accompanied by a certainty
that if only the elusive being would
return our smiles come for dinner or
Marius we would know bliss epochal
happiness seems tantalizingly close holy
real and yet maddeningly out of reach at
such moments were often counseled to try
to forget the beloved we should given
their lack of interest try to think of
someone or something else yet this
kindness is deeply misguided the cure
for love does not lie in ceasing to
think of the fugitive lover but in
learning to think more intensely and
constructively about who they might
really be from close up every human
who's ever lived
proves deeply challenging we are all at
close quarters trying propositions with
short tempered vain deceitful crass
sentimental woolly cold / emotional and
chaotic what prevents us from holding
all this in mind in relation to certain
people is simply a lack of knowledge we
assume on the basis of a few charming
outside details that the target of our
passion may miraculously have escaped
the fundamentals of the human condition
they haven't we just haven't got to know
them properly this is what makes
unrequited love so intense long-lasting
and vicious by preventing us from
properly growing close to them the
beloved also prevents us from tiring of
them in the cathartic and liberating
manner that is the gift of required love
it isn't their charms that are keeping
us magnetized it is our lack of
knowledge of their flaws the cure for
unrequited love is in structure
therefore very simple we must get to
know them better the more we discovered
of them the less they would ever look
like the solution to all our problems we
would discover the endless small ways in
which they were Aksum we'd get to know
how stubborn how critical our cold and
how hurt by things that strike us as
meaningless they could be that is if we
got to know them better we'd realize how
much they had in common with everyone
else
passion can never withstand too much
exposure to the full reality of another
person the unbounded admiration on which
it's founded is destroyed by the
knowledge which a properly shared life
inevitably brings the cruelty of
unrequited love isn't really that we
haven't been loved back rather it's that
our hopes have been aroused by someone
who can never disappoint us someone who
we will have to keep believing in
because we lack the knowledge that would
set us free we must in the absence of a
direct cure undertake an imaginative one
we must accept without quite knowing the
details that they would of course
eventually prove decisively irritating
everyone does we have to believe this
not because we know it exactly of them
but because they are in the end human
and we know this dark but deeply
cheering fact about everyone who has
ever lived
thank you for watching liking and
subscribing if you want more why not
visit us in person and attend a class or
take a look at our shop at the link on
your screen now